and then Catherine bringing together
using the last top of the
she some really interesting institute in
fact she's directing and was
instrumental in helping that place
organized and set up in the way it is
also instituted big f it said climate a
research center climate and vibrates the
research center associated with the
senckenberg museum any we will know the
centerburg museum germany with a
preeminent and Natural History
Collection and the state of hesse it
made the decision well we really need to
connect our museum up to some a
world-class biodiversity and global
change science because that's what
drives the headlines these days and
makes us relevant to the museum so
really one of the few museums that I
know that that fold and successfully
went that route and I think it's
actually a real interesting example for
us here at the l and and other places
around the world to hopefully do similar
steps and so she's directing that
institute and his driving has been
driving our own research group in the
area of fighting climate change for a
long time we've known each other for a
long time and it's very beautiful to
have you here in yoga vez introduction
and thank you very much for the
invitation and for the opportunity to
listen to all the other very interesting
talks this is hurricane katrina about 24
hours before it hit the coast of the
united states and basically drown New
Orleans and made everybody aware of it
climate change with his associated
extreme events together with land use
change in this case the loss of
mangroves can have severe impact also
for humans on the economy on social
systems and maybe even on political
systems however at the end of the day
and as the last talked we have to
honestly ask ourselves if we have really
the tools to predict our project but the
impact of climate change and other
global change factors is on Byron
versity so to focus my target a little
bit more I want to address in my talk of
the questions how do we predict the
impact of global change on biodiversity
on a global scale and the large drivers
have been mentioned before its climate
change lenses change exploitation
invasion of exotic species and pollution
and starting right with climate change
there's a very good tool box that people
have used profoundly in projecting the
impact of climate change and species
distributions basically you take
observed records of a species then build
a model in this case of the red-backed
shrike using precipitation and
temperatures predictor variables and
then you use scenarios and changes in
temperature and precipitation for the
future and project a range into the
future and in this case this model was
based on observations on 1970s and
projected into 1990s and it was
predicted that the red bag tribe would
expand its range of the whole of Great
Britain including the Shetland Islands
and what makes this example so
interesting is that we have in fact
observed data for the species 4 1990 and
that's the special distribution of the
red peg strike as it was actually
observed 1990 so it's a very sobering
example of our ability to protect ranges
into the future not all of these models
are so bad in fact most of them are not
but still that there's a lot of work to
do and to improve our models and to make
these protections better and there has
been already a lot of thought on what
factors need to be considered and this
is the list that people have come up
with we have to consider land use change
obviously the decline of the redfish rag
in Great Britain is probably driven by
changes in habitat so multiple drivers
and the
actions among those drivers are
important biotic interactions need to be
considered transient dynamics has to be
considered dispersal population dynamics
adaptation of species a long list and if
you sit down and think about it a little
bit more it's we have to realize that
these factors or mechanisms can be
arranged along different spatial scales
so if we work from the community over
the landscape continental and global
scale many of these factors that are
missing in the species distribution
models are based here at the community
scale for example habited population
dynamics biotic interactions are usually
studied investigated thought to be
important at the community scale then we
have metal population dynamics and
dispersal thought to be important at the
landscape scaled colonization speciation
earth history at the large spatial
skills if we are now looking at our
threats global climate change is
probably impacting ranges of species
globally so it's actually acting and
impacting on a global scale but many of
the other threats of impact populations
and smaller spatial skills pollution is
usually local unless we are dealing of
lakes also lend use change is stepwise
and usually local exotic species
exploitation is also acting rather at
the landscape maybe continental scale so
the things that we look at in species
distribution modeling and other modeling
efforts our response variable the
geographic range of species is here at
the continental or global scale so what
we basically investigated what we have
to ask ourselves if processes that are
acting at these small spatial scales
land-use change changes in ecological
communities habited basically reflect up
to the geographic range of species
and have an impact on their continental
and global scale just to remind
ourselves most of the studies on land
use are connected at this landscape
scale your own studies in East Africa
here in kakamega forest where we had
plots different sides of the forest and
head sites that were fragmented and
others that were less fragmented and an
impact of local human disturbance in
terms of selective flocking and we
looked at the impact of those two
factors forest fragmentation and local
disturbance on the diversity of a whole
range of species and on there so ciated
access system processes or functions
like bees and pollination birds and seed
dispersal and so on and then we
investigated for these five different
groups here the impact of fragmentation
and of logging on the community
composition in this case of bees and on
pollination and the heavy ever errors
point2 highly significant connections
and it boils down that first
fragmentation is very much impacting the
composition of a collection communities
the processes are rather influenced by
selective logging and sometimes we have
a significant impact of the ecological
community on the process but that's
rather rare but basically the main
message is lend use metals at this
landscape scale now how do we get land
use in the species distribution models
at a continental or larger scale now
here we build land use models in this
case as an example that for the rock
rock bunting in Europe where we on the
first hand that the only climatic were a
predictor variables and here we had not
only climatic but also land use a
predictor variables and we we
investigated a lot of thought in picking
for each species specifically the
fitting land use variables from using
this broad
and categories of the Carina dataset and
for the species the model really got
better they're blue points are correct
predictions of the model and what we
reduced in the combined model including
land use as the red errors which is
commissioned over prediction errors so
if we consider the habitat and the
models get and can get in some cases
much better a second example that if we
use habited variables in this case tree
species richness and we can get a much
better understanding and what is
happening in our communities this is a
map of species richness of birds in
Africa with the high peaks in the
tropical mountain areas and here we have
the species richness of the applicant
frugivores birds that are mainly eating
fruits and in comparison a map of the
species richness of the genus ficus the
figs which is a keystone genus for many
frugivores and because it's supporting
basically their frugivores also through
their lean times and basically providing
the staple diet of fruit throughout the
year we were asking ourselves which
factors determine the species richness
of frugivores in each grid cell and we
used the number of abiotic predictor
variables like the altitudinal range of
the grid cell maximum temperature
precipitation net primary production and
ecosystem diversity and we set up these
links a priority based on our
expectation that for example NPP is
influenced by temperature and
precipitation as hypothesis to test
which of these factors influence
fujiwara species richness and basically
invented a path analysis and tested the
significance of all these factors and
the best predictor of fergie world
diversity was here precipitation now
when we put the diversity of ficus as an
additional predictor variable into this
path model their impact on species
richness of fergie was changes and now
the species richness of ficus is the
best and variable predicting it and
focus itself is influenced by
precipitation and now the direct link
between precipitation to frugivores is
still significant but much weaker so
basically this is a way of getting a
little bit more mechanistic
understanding of what is determining
species richness it's obviously
correlated with precipitation by this
impersonalist suggests that the actual
causal link is not direct but indirect
through the species richness of ficus
and this simple simple all this improved
understanding on the relationships can
now be used in projections on species
richness into the future this is a map
of Kenya where we try to make
projections on the impact of climate
change on the species richness of birds
and we used a symbol basically multiple
regression model where we projected
species richness into the future using
only climatic predictor variables here
to the left and we have clients of
species richness and the north and south
east and increases in central kenya and
then we added to the model and the
species richness of trees as an
additional predictor variable and then
we made two scenarios first we let the
trees adjust immediately and instantly
to climate change basically protected
the trees into the future as well or
will it left the trees as they were and
no change in tree species richness and
if we assume that trees respond
immediately just climate change the
projection is identical to the
projection without trees basically these
models also for mathematical reasons so
models that just use abiotic predictor
variables not
including anything like trees basically
assume that all the intermediate steps
between the abiotic change event and the
response of the birds that they respond
instantaneously which is obviously not
true of we're dealing with trees that
need hundreds of years to grow and if we
in this scenario keep the trees as they
are the projections are completely
different we now predict decreases in
species richness of birds in the whole
of Kenya so this basically demonstrates
that we don't consider such transient
dynamics and don't include the habitat
or the trees and our models our
projections might be mean vastly wrong
so to summarize this part and it is
possible to include habitat and biotic
interactions in species distribution
models and it is also important because
it definitely makes a difference it
leads to it can lead to vastly different
results if we are not considering them
next step to moving a little bit up the
spatial scale to the landscape scale and
now ask or the dispersal might influence
also our geographic distributions of
animals and plants and again I'm
starting at the landscape scale and at
the scale where traditional Studies on
the effect of dispersal are conducted
and I'm asking here whether different
habitat types like closed forest or
agricultural land with very isolated
trees if these differences inhabited
changed the movement behavior of animals
and change the dispersal colonel they
generate for trees we did this study
with trumpeter horn balls in South
Africa that are quite right resized to
carry one of these new generation of a
GPS receivers where you can basically
locate the position of the bird with GPS
quality and can lock the transmitter in
a way that you can collect continuous or
semi continuous
later in this case we collected a
location data point every 15 minutes and
that's basically a day in the bird of
the day in the of the bird Ben and he is
starting out here in our be God's nature
reserve an early morning sleeping here
in the gorge and it's leaving the God
and flying through the sugar cane
spending here a quick stop over in a
ficus tree you can see the burned areas
and the sugar came until it reaches a
little fragmented forest while spending
about an hour hour and a half turning
back to a farm garden where it's feeding
on of often exotic fruit species and
then moving on through the landscape
spending another two hours or so in a
next forest fragment than here visiting
the farm of Stewart and Bonita poachers
who became good friends of ours because
the birds spend a lot of time in their
farm and in the afternoon and against
evening flew back to or we got so with
these new devices were able to get a
completely new understanding on the
movement behavior of animals in the
landscape and we can then use these data
together with a feeding trials like we
measure the gut message time of the
birds to understand the city's personal
kernels that the birds are generating
here is a picture of the landscape in
which the birds are moving here's the
scale 10 kilometers and each dark patch
is a first patch that the birds visited
in each red line is a connection where
we have a time window where seed
dispersal can occur so basically all the
red lines are giving us a picture of the
functional connectivity of landscape and
basically a picture of stepping stones
and dispersal corridors in the landscape
and the second thing that we can do
look at dispersal kernels in different
habitat types here in forest the
distance and seeds were moved it's a
unimodal distribution with a mean
dispersal distance of about a hundred
and sixty meters but in agriculture land
it's very different we suddenly have a
bimodal distribution seeds are
transported either really short
distances when the birds are moving in
one of these farm gardens or forest
fragments or they are transported long
distances 512 meters on average and
obviously the mean distance between the
different patches so here the in
movement ecologies muted technological
advancements we have the potential to
get much better dispersal data than we
dreamed off in the past but as dispersal
metaphor geographic distributions we
investigated this with the sylvia walk
blossom very well studied genus and
old-world genus where we have some
species like Sylvia Kunis with huge
breeding and wintering ranges and other
species like Sylvia soda with very small
breeding and wintering ranges and what
we looked at is range filling so that's
the relationship between the realized
range and the potential range that can
be calculated through species
distribution modeling basically all the
area where the same vegetation abiotic
conditions consist as in the realized
range and from this quotient we can see
which factors might influence the
realized range of a species and as
predictor variables we used rather
simple predictors and but they measure
different biotic interactions and
dispersal for dispersal we measure the
wing pointed pneus of the birds for
competition we met measured the species
richness of khan gina's in the same grid
cell we looked at phylogenetic age and
the shift of the vegetation since the
last glacial maximum
maximum to investigate what if it
matters if species that had to move a
long distance since the lgm and had a
little lower range filling than species
that basically didn't have to move very
much and first of all range filling is
quite variable we had differences
between thirty one percent up to ninety
one-percent range filling and the best
predictor variables was an interaction
between dispersal and competition hiya
strange feeling was present in species
that had good dispersal ability and few
competitors in their potential range and
species that had either a low dispersal
ability or high dispersal ability but
many competitors could fill their
potential range only to a smaller degree
so obviously dispersal matters also at
the geographic scale also for the
geographic ranges of species and even
for such animals like birds that are
highly mobile so to summarize this part
obviously these factors that operate at
the community and landscape scale metal
also for geographic distributions of
animals and plants and it is important
to include them into the models because
as shown by these projections if we are
not including them or predict
predictions can be really vastly wrong
and to somewhere and put up just a
little other story in in addition mean
what we haven't talked about here very
much as ecosystem services however with
IP bears and other initiatives in this
direction is obvious that biodiversity
is only the first step but that we have
to look beyond biodiversity and also
look at ecosystem functions in
especially ecosystem services however
for our as biologists it has been not
easy to approach ecosystem services and
a nice framework
well the variety of steps where
biodiversity comes into the ecosystem
service framework has been developed by
Georgina maize and collaborators she
pointed out that biodiversity metals her
ecosystem services at different levels
it matters at the ecosystem process
level where biodiversity can act as a
regulator of ecosystem processes for
example in pollination it matters as a
final ecosystem service for example we
have trees and that produce apples for
direct for human consumption and at a
third step by diversity matters because
it can be in some circumstances a good
by itself that has an economical value
by itself here exemplified by the
Mauritius Kestrel or people play I pay
quite a lot of money to be able to see
this bird of a willing to pay money to
preserve the species and I've been
looking here at the direct value of
biodiversity in a system whether link
between biodiversity and ecosystem
services is a little bit easier to draw
than in many other systems we are
looking here at African savannas or we
know that climatic factors influence the
vegetation which is influencing the
ungulates the large predators and the
Predators are attracting the tourists so
we have here a system where we have
direct links between by the abiotic
factors of one hand the biodiversity in
the middle and the tourists as ecosystem
service at the end when again this is a
level where people have looked at
ecosystem services at a community or
landscape scale again I'm asking is it
possible to draw these ecosystems
services also to a larger macro
ecological scale and we did this by
doing a comparative analysis across
multiple national power
in Africa 63 in the meantime will be
compiled data on all these different
factors large mammal densities tourist
numbers and then and arrange them across
a climatic gradient and again did a path
analysis to disentangle the different
factors we get in very nice correlations
in that rainfall is increasing the angle
a density temperature significantly
decreasing it the Predators are most
significantly influenced by the angle
identities less or not at all by
temperature and rainfall and the
tourists are in fact significantly
influenced by predator densities and
also to some degree by temperature if
it's too hot then they are fewer
tourists so we have here nice system
where we can plot ecosystem services in
a more mechanistic way in space and
where we can also use no predictions for
future scenarios and rainfall and
temperature to protect it into the
future and with a difference that in
many previous ecosystem service studies
it was basically just a mapping of
ecosystem services in space using GIS
approaches whereas this is a step
forward to towards a more mechanistic
approach so to summarize I hope I could
demonstrate you that also for this
global scale it's important to
understand the community processes that
are underlying the global distributions
and that it is possible to include
things like habitat of biotic
interactions or dispersal or even
ecosystem services in macro ecological
models and projections thank you for
your attention
take so much cut ring for extending our
discussions here to bring in species
interactions and the more mechanistic
thinking about some of those models we
have time for a few questions for
catching and actually at that time I
also want to open up the floor we have
happily five or a little more minutes
anything sort of came back to your mind
about any of the talks earlier today
you're at the end of the symposium and
I'm happy to take some more more general
questions before we move on to a smaller
discussion next door cafe
ok
together
please
okay the
send your ass
chief Atlee
visionary way
Oh
the
I just can't yeah what we try to rely on
it for uh you know what's the work with
developing countries doing this the
old-school kind of systematic really
really put that's a 5,000 potshot middle
the congo forest which private voluntary
carbon stock change with this very
labor-intensive you know some old-school
approach fixed pots and what we're
saying is the dynamics we see the
dynamics why don't we do a more
stratified approach where you target the
dynamic and then you get in a more
efficient way understand that it could
be known as biodiversity see we know
where the changes occurring so you can
imagine these growing and shrinking
strata of land dynamics of the
biodiversity whatever which whatever it
is you measure will correlate with in
the absence of a presence of this
disturbance so you know we think
the way to target field resources maybe
in a more more guided way based on mr.
those really enters the bird the bird
like the exotic fruit trees right it was
simple it chased the looked like it was
living in an apple to this food source
that was generally provided and you know
you'll find that that burden a more
natural environment we had a totally
different life cycle so yeah partition
the landscapes of the more or less
natural more or less disturbance
and yam other more comments or questions
we covered a lot of ground yesterday and
today in a bit we've been every single
talk actually we would cover a lot of
ground by definition given that you had
the global charge here well I'd like to
thank you the Ale community from Gibbs
supporting us attending participating
also from the folks from also want to
thank the folks from out of town from
Stony Brook and New York and Boston get
people come in from from the
surroundings to join us for this the
things for for coming and participating
thanks to Katherine for the final talk
thanks to the speakers of this afternoon
and thanks to all speakers in fact for
for making the trip from Australia from
Europe Colorado so really appreciate it
I hope I'm not trying to not going to
try and summarize of synthesize these
two days we as I said it with a broad
spectrum of taxa scales ideals
approaches that we've had but that was
in a way the idea to sort of show you
the whole smorgasbord if you will the
whole all the facets of how we can
possibly get it tackling the geography
of biodiversity and the threats of
biodiversity in ideally great detail but
a representative Lee across the whole
globe and I hope that they really
excellent speakers that we've had the
real leaders in their respective fields
the came to Yale I hope that I brought
it across the challenge and exciting
opportunities and and
some pathways to potential solutions and
that you are with us excited about that
as an important area of research at Yale
with some of those global initiatives
that are going on and as a whole for for
us to educate ourselves and do more work
in the future with that let me thank
catherine the speakers of this afternoon
and all of the speakers for coming
together here deal